nous avons parlé de votre
le prochain sommet avec Biden donc
Je ne peux pas m'empêcher de poser des questions à ce sujet
avez déjà dit que vous ne vous attendez pas à des percées de
Cette réunion
mais quel serait le minimum pour toi
disons un résultat positif
vous savez, il me semble que pour restaurer notre
nouer des relations personnelles
dialogue direct
créer un véritable mécanisme de fonctionnement
et la coopération dans ces domaines
qui présentent un intérêt mutuel et
tel est aussi le côté américain
il dit la même chose et est généralement d'accord avec lui
il y a vraiment une série de questions
sont d'intérêt et de crainte mutuels
stabilité stratégique stabilité
préoccupation originelle du conflit pour l'environnement
dans son ensemble dans un sens global, c'est-à-dire qu'il y a
la question est où pouvons-nous vraiment
travailler efficacement et parler sur le terrain
l'économie est aussi mutuelle
intérêt il y a beaucoup d'entreprises
Les américains veulent travailler pour nous
les oreilles sortent notre marché n'est pas inférieur
placer un concurrent sur le fait qu'il y a du trafic
au profit de l'économie américaine en général
il y a quelque chose à dire et des sujets si communs
oui, si après cette réunion nous créons
mécanisme pour tous ces
les directions ne semblent pas être de la glace
eh bien on pourrait dire que la rencontre
n'est pas passé jusqu'à